alex we had you here last night uh after
a big win and then today you came out
all guns blazing ray's already broken
down a lot of the moves from the game
itself but we want to know what's the
deal with that prep because you were
just whipping out the moves move after
move yeah well first of all i have to
thank one of my friends um because i
remember we were discussing at some
point uh this line and he just said yeah
d4 is dangerous and nice d4 is a
dangerous move for white and i said i
said cd and then f6 the way carl's no
problem he said no there's queen a4 it's
not so easy so he was the first one who
told me that oh there's this queen a4
move and then of course you know i
started to do some work on it and i it's
still very dangerous but i thought okay
for one game
it should probably be fine and then the
rest of it is i have to give credit
where credit is due stockfish 14.
where did it stop when did you feel like
uh
this is different from what i know
i think i didn't quite i was already
vaguely remembering that i was supposed
to be getting back to pawn in various
ways but then he played knight d5 and i
didn't have castles long in my prep but
it looked like the only move and i saw
it of course when i went into the line i
saw that knight d5 i could castle and i
calculated it's not so bad but i think
at that point i was already not quite in
my prep but i was still playing
relatively quickly because i was i
thought i had mostly only moves anyway
and i was thinking a lot on his time as
well and i ended up needing that time
later on anyway so
i guess it was okay um but yeah i mean
i'm sure
we both didn't play perfectly but yeah
it was a very tough fight
do you feel like there was a moment uh
critical moment in the game where you
could have really played better or do
you think that it's a fair result oh
well it definitely was a fair result i
think both of us us had some chances he
defended really well in the end game at
some point but i would say my best
chance was instead of giving that check
on c2 i think it was or d2 i could have
played this uh
where's
yes here yeah i thought i could have
played king b7 and that's another move i
i considered and i kind of regret not
playing it because yeah and his time
pressure could have you know given him
practical problems somehow i thought
rook c2 is really good for me but i
think i underestimated some of his
counterplay i don't even remember what
exactly i missed but i think i kind of
underestimated king f3 that it's you
know i i taking the pawn on h2 he just
gets too much counter play but yeah i
kind of saw the move king b7 and i you
know it's flexibility rook f8 or rook c2
in some cases yeah so i kind of regret
not playing that i think that was my
best chance to pose a lot of practical
problems
but yeah other than that i can't say i'm
i'm not unhappy obviously it was a very
good fight i did my best he also did his
best and i think it was a fair result
good place for you right now there was
just one tricky moment right here which
we thought was kind of uh amusing uh
you've taken the pawn there was a move
bishop d4
bishop d4 right here instead of taking
on h2 did you take a look uh yeah i
didn't see the movement bishop d4 at all
yeah i think var showed me over there uh
yeah i just did not see that move at all
even though i spent a lot of time here
but yeah somehow i didn't see that at
all it was an amusing uh
masking move there although i don't
think i'm necessarily winning or
anything like that but yeah some
probably if i would have seen that i
maybe i would have played it but yeah i
was thinking i was considering a lot of
other moves but yeah this move somehow
never occurred to me
thanks well congratulations then on a
solid result with the black pieces good
luck tomorrow thank you so much
absolutely alex good luck two co-leaders